Gary I watched a video interview that
you did where he talked about for a
while you were in San Francisco he had
long flowing hair and you're kind of
lost soul you know and it sounded
actually very romantic and intriguing
what if someone's over 35 over 40 and
there's sort of that one or that lost
soul and they are having trouble
harnessing these creative ideas because
we know a lot of dreamers you talked
about for a while you were that way or a
dreamer and all these great ideas but
what a lot of dreamers seem to have is
they don't harness those concrete ideas
they don't get them done how do you fix
that
is that a matter of discipline you hit
the word I mean there are people who are
dreamers I was a dreamer I went to law
school in part not because I want to be
an attorney because I wanted to learn an
adult language and indiscipline at a
framework where I could ground myself
because I really was quite a dreamer and
it worked and I am very disciplined in
my approach to stuff which is you know I
mean it's one of the great paradox who
wrote the book flow in the book
creativity who talks about the ten
paradoxes of the creative personality
and one of them is that you are sort of
you know a creative person is all at
once
sort of playful and and
unstructured and at the same time
incredibly disciplined right they are
they live in fantasy worlds but they're
really done I mean doggedly attached to
rooted in in pragmatic reality there are
all these paradoxes if someone is purely
a dreamer it's going to be tough right
at some point you you you either get so
frustrated that you say I need a plan
and I need to pursue I need to take
troubies course I need to take McKee's
course I need to find some mentors I
need to invest X number of hours every
day every day or they're just never
going to make any progress I mean that's
the truth they won't so you get out of
things what you put into them we know
that we're taught that and it's true
that's it takes hard work it I bread you
know someone asked me how did how do you
how are you so fast with story and
restructuring story working with writers
and writing yourself and all that and
and the truth is that I this was about
five years ago ten years ago I forget
and I realized at that time I said
conservatively you know could you figure
out how many scripts you bred I realized
it was over 10,000 scripts not all of
which obviously but a number of which I
had actually given notes on and
rewritten with writers or you know notes
on on revisions I had put in so many
hours they say mastery takes 10,000
hours I don't know if that's actually
mathematically true for everybody but
it's a right idea the discipline to stay
the course and say you know what I am
going to commit to a daily practice that
includes so much time toward becoming
what a fill-in-the-blank
the screenwriter associate with other
screenwriters take courses write X
number of hours a day read scripts X
number of hours I mean just really live
it if it matters that much to you I hate
a in fairness this big point you talk
about someone over 35 or 40 doesn't
matter
they say that Hollywood is Aegis
and there's some truth to that and I say
pay no mind who cares when you submit a
script they don't know what you look
like they have no idea how old you are
they're reading a creative work that's
your issue right when you show up and
they want to buy it when you show up
believe me if they really have a purpose
behind their decision to buy it they're
going to buy it you can do things
independently there's a lot of ways I
think that people stop themselves but if
they're 35 or 40 and they're dreaming
and they've been dreaming for 40 years
and they've never disciplined themselves
and they've never really practiced
success principles it's going to be
tough so your rehab so to speak
Gary's rehab for dreamers would be get
that daily practice associate with other
people of like mine you know watch
material that you want to have made
things like that it's interesting to me
is there's a lot of quote study groups
and there's a lot of networking and I
see go on but I'm wondering sometimes
how much work is really behind the
scenes you know a lot of people on
social media tweeting and that's all
great but then I'm curious how much
actual work gets done and I think
sometimes those dreamers myself included
I fall into this category get caught up
this of that other stuff and then the
real work doesn't get done I think many
of us would agree that a lot of what we
call networking whether it's through
social media or in person is it's not
the most productive time ever invested
that it could be a wormhole of that
really leads to no great value and I had
a I had a very successful business a
friend of mine in real estate every year
he comes up with a new tagline for print
for that year for himself which I
thought that's interesting
so his tagline the other year a year or
two ago was um
fewer what was the I'm sorry it's taking
a second fewer bigger deals you were
better people and I thought wonderful
he's really going
against he's swimming upstream right
he's look he's the Sam and he's going
upstream he's the one who's going
against the trend of spending more and
more hours in social media and so on and
so forth and it all happened because he
lost his blackberry and he lost all the
data and he decided that he only needed
six people that was it was six great
people in your life all of whom
recommitted to helping each other
realize their dream and using the
rolodex for the benefit of everybody in
that circle that was all you ever needed
and he's closed that that that sounds
true to me more than not so I think this
idea like networking aimlessly to know
superficially to walk home with a bunch
of business cards motive ed I'm not sure
how useful that
you